this is top 10 view Insanity I was a
migrant an immigrant in Miami they need
to be resettled elsewhere spre out this
massive country well and it's only going
to get worse with global warming and
climate change cuz people can't live in
certain parts of this world they need to
be resettled elsewhere do you guys know
the phrase nimi not in my backyard it's
the hypocrisy of these Elite rich women
they don't give a when this is happening
in the Border towns of Texas so this
idea first off they have to be resettled
also there's like a twang of like Nazism
in there we'll resettle these dirty
people they can't all be here spread
them out throughout the country how
about you can't come into the country in
the first place okay you want to spread
people out how about outside of the
United States that might be okay and
then finally joyless bayar with her yes
it's climate change guys it's just going
to keep happening because of climate
change but we can't have everybody
coming to the Upper West Side